we will be seeing plenty of marquee
teams this year in the post in the
regular season there are 10 teams 10
that have five prime time games each i
was stunned to see that many on the list
and i was stunned to see
so many teams on the list that struggled
last year it's one thing to put the
patriots and the rams the two super bowl
teams in prime time five times the
chiefs and the bears five times cowboys
five times seahawks a little bit of a
surprise five times but the steelers
eagles vikings and packers each have
five prime time games i the packers were
six nine and one the vikings stink in
prime time
i was surprised to see you know the
thing about it three teams in the nfc
north three out of four teams will have
five prime time games yeah it is pretty
amazing i don't think
the list does not surprise me i mean the
names you mentioned at the end there yes
i mean hey the steelers come on we know
that's a national power a national brand
franchise quarterback you know still
have stars on their football team the
eagles hey they they could have very
easily been in the nfc championship game
last year uh so i understand that you
know the green bay packers it is aaron
rodgers uh and they are of course a
national brand i think the most shocking
one of that list is your squad mike the
minnesota vikings i i really am
surprised to see them uh on the you know
top tier as far as primetime games good
football team but you know yes it's a
quarterback that has a stigma of not
being able to win prime time games like
you talk about uh and last year wasn't a
great year i just you know i don't know
minnesota seems to be the team that
jumps out to me more than the rest on
there when we interviewed mike zimmer
the vikings coach at the league meetings
last month in arizona he he made a very
pragmatic point look you're in those
games you're playing against good teams
so you've got to rise to the occasion
and last year the vikings failed to do
it but i know from conversations chris
that we have had off the record offer
some of the best conversations we have
with guests like at the super bowl
happen when we get away from
the microphones and away from the
cameras it became clear to me that that
there's a belief in minnesota that that
there's something to this and that they
give him grief in the locker room about
the inability to win the primetime games
and one of those prime time games is
coming up on a thursday night when his
old team comes to town the washington
franchise with case keenum who hasn't
been in u.s bank stadium since the
minneapolis miracle assuming he's the
quarterback when week 8 rolls around
adrian peterson
returning to minnesota as well and i
remember when you know we started
talking about revenge games this year i
said that game is good enough once case
kingdom joined washington to put it in
prime time and here it is in prime time
week 8 on a thursday night and uh that's
one of those and the vikings had been
lobbying for
a short week home game they're short
week games in recent years they've had
to go on the road yeah that's right had
to go to l.a this year they get to be at
home for that short week game and uh and
they're only in detroit the week before
so it's not like it's a long trip home
before they get ready for the thursday
night matchup against washington yeah
that's right and you know the other
thing that jumps out to me yes it's five
pre you know prime time games right with
your minnesota vikings uh and we'll be
watching closely but you know two of
those sunday night appearances are later
in the year to where you know they're
going to have to earn them right i mean
let's say week 10 am i correct with that
that's at the dallas cowboys that's
supposed to be a sunday night matchup
and then you have the week 15 at los
angeles chargers if the minnesota
vikings aren't playing well especially
in that chargers matchup that could be
one that maybe gets flexed or changed
either way so there is that dynamic
about it even though you're scheduled
for prime time games if it's sunday
night football uh and you're not playing
well you might not have a prime time
game
well let me point something out here
week 10 is before the bar for flexing
gets a lot lower
or 11. week 11 week 11 is when the flex
really starts there's that option week
six to ten in the event that there's a
torn acl suffered by a quarterback
gotcha happened last year to 49ers
quarterback jimmy garoppolo there was a
flex in that window i believe but first
of all they're playing the cowboys
especially the chargers one that was the
one i looked at but yes well especially
especially because maybe the chargers
aren't going to be very good i think
both teams have to hold up their end of
the bargain because there will be
attractive match ups with two potential
playoff teams late in the year and the
vikings could be 11-3 going into that
game but if the chargers are three and
11 that game isn't going to be played in
prime time so both teams are a factor in
whether or not those late season prime
time games stick and we we saw a lot of
flexing last year and it's something the
nfl does and the nfl has especially with
new tv deals on the immediate horizon
you want to ensure that the best games
are being played it's in the nfl's best
interest to put the best games in prime
time because it creates a bigger
audience a bigger rating more buzz and
ultimately allows the the networks to
justify paying more money for that
property if you're giving the network
some more valuable property they're
going to pay more money for it it's
basic economics yeah no i i get it and
you know the nfl and nbc and everybody
have done a great job of making the
sunday night matchups especially last
year i really don't remember any duds
that we had i mean i thought every
matchup was compelling good and that's
the way it should be especially when
there's only one game on that night or
whatever it may be i want to see the
best the best teams when i can just sit
there on the couch and focus on on one
game and uh it makes a lot of sense from
the nfl standpoint and for you know the
broadcast networks
do we worry about teams like the bears
and maybe to a lesser extent the chiefs
having so many prime time games because
last year the bears were able to compile
a great record kind of under the radar
this year they're going to be a team
that people are focused on trying to
beat and they're going to have this
schedule where you know you jump around
you play you you disrupt your your
routine every coach would prefer to
start at 1 pm eastern every week and uh
matt nagy is going to have to adjust
very quickly to having that that five
prime time game lineup as he goes into
his second season yeah it's not easy and
you're right this is gonna be a
different year this is not like oh we're
gonna catch you by surprise we're the
chicago bears this year everybody knows
they're extremely talented yes but
there's still some you know young
unproven aspects to their team to a to a
degree and we know that you know the nfc
north got better the lions have gotten
better in free agency the green bay
packers did as well and aaron rodgers
and the new coach and of course the
minnesota vikings are a very talented
team to begin with
so yeah i mean this will be a big test
and as i mentioned in the first hour
these night games uh they do throw you
players coaches are are creatures of
habit they really are i mean especially
in football and when you get their own
night games and travel and getting home
really late or really early in the
morning and it messes up your
preparation going into the next week
like i talked about not only is it
grueling on the players it's more
grueling on the coaches i think they're
the ones that take the brunt of oh my
gosh i'm exhausted i had to pull an
all-nighter because we landed at five in
the morning and i had to hit the ground
running monday morning because you know
we got a big game or tuesday morning if
you come off monday night football and
that's not easy it can wear you out
yeah and these are all very real factors
as you go through that grind week in and
week out of a football season it's
amazing the hours they put in and any
disruption to what would be a normal
routine there's nothing normal about
football season but when you have that
short week game when you've got the
monday night game and then you've got to
fly home and maybe you've got a road
game the following weekend i think the
packers are the only team this year that
has a road game on a monday night
followed by a road game the following
sunday which is not an easy thing to do
and one bit of good news for the
dolphins and the bengals they're the
only two teams this year who do not have
a short week thursday game wow on one
hand you can say we're being
disrespected on the other hand you can
say hey this is great we don't have to
turn around and play on a thursday night
yeah it is great i think the players
will think it's great you know that's
never easy honestly which
this is the coaches like thursday night
football mike that's one where i bet you
the bengals and dolphins coaches are
going to be a little disappointed yes
you have to cram a lot into a three-day
period but there's only so much you can
cram in in that three-day period as far
as getting your team prepared on a
monday tuesday wednesday for a thursday
game but where coaches really love that
thursday game is it's almost like a semi
bye week another bye week because then
you do get a really relaxed friday
saturday sunday schedule for an nfl
coach who really has no days off when
that when once training camp starts that
might be thursday game the coach might
throw you a bone and say you know what
guys take friday and saturday off i'll
see you guys here sunday because he's
still got an extra day of preparation
for the team he got coming up the next
week so i bet you zach taylor and brian
flores saw that and went damn it are you
kidding me we didn't get a thursday
night game i would have liked that day
of rest or whatever it may be that comes
with it
so you give the players an extra day or
two off so you can take an extra day or
two that's exactly it and you got to
give the players an extra day or two off
i mean when you play you know two
physical games in in a what is that a 72
96 hour window uh the players are
definitely gonna need to kind of rest
and catch up a little bit so if i tell
you to take tomorrow off does that mean
i get tomorrow deal nope you got to be
here you're you're you're the big money
i'm a player you're a coach get in here
grind away let's go
when we return we're going to answer
some of your questions related to the
schedule plus anything else that catches
our attention more pft live coming at
you right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports